President Biden met with Mexican
president oor yesterday praising their
partnership in tackling The Surge of
illegal immigrants and drugs crossing
our Southern border meanwhile House
Republicans released a jaw-dropping
report revealing nearly half a trillion
of your tax dollars have gone to the
Border crisis under Biden Congressman
August fluger is with the house Homeland
Security committee and the house Foreign
Affairs committee and he joins us now
Congressman wouldn't it have just been
cheaper to just build a
wall Rachel absolutely and when you look
at the very first quote from the Mexican
president praising Joe Biden for not
building the wall being the first
president to not build wall to look for
legal Pathways I mean you know it's kind
of the The Twilight Zone because it's
clear that the president is not standing
up for us and the Mexican president is
AB is applauding him for that I mean his
first job is to stand up for Americans
he's clearly not doing that so where's
our money going where's that money going
when you look at it's a staggering
amount of money um what's the utility of
it yeah 450 billion dollar as you
mentioned almost a half a trillion
dollars to US taxpayers let's just start
in Texas 10 billion plus to operation
loone star you've got Yuma Regional with
26 million in medical expenses you have
farmers and ranchers whose fences and
ranch homes and properties being
destroyed and not to mention the cost of
crime I mean in my district we had the
unfortunate incident where a family lost
their the grandmother and the child this
is happening everywhere and that is
costing counties millions of dollars to
process those crimes it's just insane
you know what the dollar amount is
staggering let me make one point though
the intangible of the destruction of the
rule of law is something that we will
feel for decades to come and that's
really uh very scary what what Biden is
doing to us Congressman what you know
there was this statement from from Joe
Biden during this meeting talking about
we've worked on as you mentioned a
moment ago sort of partnering together
on increasing legal Pathways into the
United States he talked about
restitution and then you've got um amlo
saying things like I want to take this
opportunity to greet our Panos the
Mexican migrants who are living and
making and working in the United States
around 40 million have made the United
States their second home their second
country I'm curious what kind of
partnership are we working on here
between Mexico and the United
States well President Biden is coming at
it from a a complete perspective
weakness I mean the the folks that come
here legally that work in this country
uh that do a good job you know become
citizens that is wonderful and we need
to continue to do that however when Amo
is talking what what he's really talking
about is they're running the trafficking
and smuggling organizations directly
through Mexico and they're not feeling
the brunt of it we are this is what
president Trump did so well as he said
we're going to put tariffs on you on all
Mexican Goods coming into the United
States if you don't help us if you don't
actually do remain in Mexico and help us
turn away migrants that's not happening
President Biden is so weak that he can't
even get to the point where he holds
them accountable for trade issues and
much less migration issues yeah I mean
we're destroying the Notions of of
citizenship that as you mentioned that's
the intangible but also the cartels are
richer and stronger than ever they're
they're they're so powerful Mexico is
practically a narco state in my view I
mean 40% of the land is controlled by
the cartels
that's absolutely right um and what
they're doing with the fentel trade the
precursors coming from China this is all
linked together the geopolitics of this
and we need a president who will stand
up to it and hold them accountable but
it's coming into our communities it's
hurting our communities you know just in
my district alone in Odessa Texas the
sheriff calls me regularly Sheriff
Griffith to tell me about the cost on
human lives this is happening in every
single American city and enough is
enough we've got to hold them
accountable that's why I'm proud of you
know speaker Johnson for making a pledge
to make border security the
priority well Congressman we appreciate
you being with us this morning go Mojo
um and uh we'll see you next time I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis